- [Kim] Hi this is Kim from Kahn Academy.
Today we're learning more
about Baker versus Carr,
a landmark Supreme Court
case decided in 1962.
Baker versus Carr grappled with an
incredibly important issue.
Whether one person's vote is
equal to another person's vote.
That seems pretty
straightforward to us now,
but as we'll learn in this video,
before Baker versus Carr,
it wasn't always the case.
To learn more, I talked with two experts.
Theodore Olson, is a
partner at the law firm
of Gibson, Dunn, and served as
Solicitor General of the United
States from 2001 to 2004.
Guy-Uriel Charles, is the
Edward and Ellen Schwarzman
Professor of Law, and
the founding director
of the Duke Law Center on
Law, Race, and Politics.
Mr. Olson, could you kind
of set the stage for us?
What was the overall historical
and political context
that led up to the issues
of Baker versus Carr?
- [Olson] Well, it is a very,
very important decision.
Earl Warren, who was
Chief Justice at the time
the case was decided, later said that
it was one of the most important decisions
of his tenure as Chief Justice.
Prior to the decision in Baker versus Carr
and a couple of subsequent decisions,
legislatures throughout the country were
organized in a way based upon geography
and other considerations
rather than population.
We take the phrase one person,
one vote for granted now.
But prior to that time,
rural counties particularly,
all over the United States
dominated state legislators,
and individuals in cities, particularly,
might be electing one representative,
when a rural county, or a
rural geographical area,
much smaller in terms of population,
would also have the same amount of votes.
So there was a disproportionate weight
to smaller communities
based upon population,
which had very significant
political consequences
with respect to allocation of money
and resources and the like.
- [Charles] So in the US,
we draw lines as a way of
aggregating voters together,
so that way we can elect people
to various representative bodies.
So the process of doing
so, drawing the lines,
is called, depending on when it's done,
reapportionment or
redistricting or districting.
So we draw lines through districts
for the purposes of representation.
And that has been the practice in the US
for basically time immemorial,
the way of districting
for the purposes of representation.
Many states, especially
in the late 19th century
to early 20th century,
refuse, they drew the lines,
in the case of Tennessee,
they drew the line
in 1901, that was the last
time they reapportioned,
where they counted the number
of voters in the state,
and then they decided how
many voters were going to be
in each particular district.
So a lot of time has passed from 1901,
when the case was decided in 1961.
And many people moved from the rural areas
to the urban areas, or
from the rural areas
to the suburbs, and the
districts were just not equal.
There weren't the same numbers of voters
in each particular district.
- [Kim] So this case took
place originally in Tennessee
and was brought by a
man named Charles Baker.
So who was Charles Baker
and why did he object to
how districting was done in Tennessee?
- [Olson] Well, he was
among a group of citizens.
In a way, like many other
Supreme Court cases,
it's an accident that his name is
the one by which we remember the case.
So he came together
along with some lawyers
and other citizens in this Tennessee area,
and brought the case, because they listed
the participants as
plaintiffs alphabetically,
Mr. Baker was the first one on the list
and he became the plaintiff.
There were a group of
citizens in Tennessee,
he was on the board of a
judicial body in Tennessee,
but he was among several
citizens who objected
to the way the state
legislature was apportioned.
- [Charles] Suppose that
we have a classroom,
let's say we have an AP History class.
And we're deciding I wanna
take the class at the dinner.
We're making two decisions,
a seafood place or a steak place.
Let's suppose that we have 10 people
in the class, and we have three districts.
So we're gonna decide on the basis
of the decisions of those three districts.
Okay, so we've got one
district of two people
who like seafood, another
district of two others
who like seafood, and a
district of six people
who like steak.
But we're gonna decide
on the basis of the votes
of each of the districts,
and then the outcome, the majority
of the votes of the district
will decide the outcome.
So remember the first
district had two people
and both of those people like seafood.
Our second district also had two people
and both of those like seafood.
And our third district had six people
and those six like steak.
Now, on the basis of the
decision of the district,
right, so each district
counts for one vote,
seafood wins two to one.
But, if you look at the
total number of people
and the total preferences,
there are actually
six people who like steak and
four people who like seafood.
So really, the decision
should be in favor of steak
as the majority of the
people, of the voters
in that classroom preferred
steak over seafood.
But we can rejigger that outcome by
just dividing the people into districts
and dividing them into unequal districts
and then saying each
district gets one vote.
Well for all intents and purposes,
this is exactly what Tennessee had done.
They basically divided
the state into districts,
so that way you can elect representatives
from that district, but
some districts only had,
let's say, 100 people, and
others had 1000 people,
and some had 400, some
had, you know, 10,000.
I'm making up the numbers
here, but just to give you
an example of what the
disparities were like.
But each counted essentially as one,
each district had one vote, even though
they weren't equal in terms
of the number of people
that were in the districts.
When a student comes to me
and says, well wait a minute,
there are many more people
here who prefer steak
since it's the majority.
I'm not going to change the system
because the system
reflects my preferences.
And it was the same thing in Tennessee,
the state legislature did
not have the incentive
to change the system, because if they did,
they would loose their seats.
- [Kim] So in Supreme
Court cases, of course,
the Supreme Court is
turning to the Constitution
for its interpretation.
So what does the Constitution
say about apportioning representatives?
Does it make any mention of
how districts are supposed to be drawn?
- [Olson] It does not,
it's very interesting
that our Constitution, as everyone knows,
gives two senators for each state,
and then apportions the
House of Representatives
by district, which is required to be
redetermined every 10
years, after the Census.
But prior to Baker versus Carr,
there was very little regard
to the fact that some
districts were more populous
than other districts, which
meant that an individual voter
in a populous district
who had the same amount,
who had a vote that was diluted,
in a sense, that he shared that vote,
or that weight of his vote
with many more persons.
And this was rampant all
over the United States,
in California, Los Angeles County,
which was 40% of the population
of the state of California,
had one representative
because it was a county
and it had lots of people in it.
And then there were three smaller counties
who had very very few people,
maybe had 10 or 15,000 people
in the county, and they
each had one vote as well.
- [Kim] Okay so Charles Baker
takes this case to the
courts, and then what happens?
How did this case make its
way through the courts?
- [Charles] Well the one
thing to think about,
the reason why Baker versus
Carr is such an important case,
we have to remember
that the federal courts,
in particular the United
States Supreme Court,
had said in a case called
Colegrove versus Green,
look we the federal
courts are not going to
involve ourselves in any of these
redistricting type cases.
We don't want to have
anything to do with them,
we don't believe we have
the power to hear them.
So in 46, the court said,
we don't think we have the power to
hear these cases, and
no matter what happens,
those are cases that belong
to the political process.
Those are not cases that
belong in the federal court,
in large part, in important part,
because we don't think the Constitution
has anything to say about those cases.
- [Olson] So when it got
to the Supreme Court,
again in Baker versus
Carr, the question was,
whether the court would
reverse that earlier decision
and decide, this is something that we,
as a court, can deal with as opposed to
something that must remain
in the political realm.
And the case was argued
twice, in April of 1961
and again in October of 1961,
the court set it for reargument
because the first time it was argued,
one of the Justices was undecided,
and they were divided four to four,
and they decided to set
it for reargument again.
And when the case was then decided
the second after the second argument,
the court ruled six to two,
one of the Justices became disabled
at the end of the deliberation,
so it was only eight rather than nine.
But they decided six to two.
The relatively narrow question,
not one person, one vote,
but the narrow question,
is this something that the Constitution
gives us permission to decide.
And reciting the 14th
Amendment to the Constitution,
which contains the well known due process
and equal protection clause,
the court in Baker versus Carr decided
we can look at the Constitution,
discern from the equal protection clause,
that there is a due process clause,
but mostly the equal protection clause,
there is a basis for us
to decide that it might
violate an individual's
Constitutional right
to equal protection of the
laws, if they're placed
in a political situation where their vote
counts less than someone else's vote.
- [Charles] And so that's the way
that the court got around that question.
And the technical legal term
is to say that these
cases are justiciable,
which means that courts can hear them,
that the federal courts have the power
to decide these types of cases.
Now the court did not
decide the second question
in Baker versus Carr,
which is okay, suppose that
that is true, right, if the court says it,
so it is now true, that federal courts
do have the power to make those decisions,
how do we determine what is the standard
that we're going to use to determine
whether the Constitution is violated.
And that question, the
court could also decide,
the court said something
to the affect that,
look, we know that there are standards,
they are available, what
we're deciding now is that
we have the power because
the equal protection clause
in fact means that the
state can't draw lines
that are so malapportioned
that they undermine
the equality of voters.
- [Kim] Baker versus Carr
says that the courts then
can rule on redistricting.
Did this bring in a flood of
cases about redistricting?
- [Charles] It did.
Once the court decided
that this was fair game,
that this was appropriate for
courts to consider whether
or not disparities in
voting power as a result
of packing people into different
districts in different ways
constituted a violation
of the Constitution.
Then, in a relatively short
term by Supreme Court standards
in 1963 and 1964, and other
decisions that all came about
before the end of the
60s, the court pronounced
in case after case, that
one person, one vote
did indeed was required
by the Constitution.
So Baker versus Carr opened the door for
a stream of decisions
from the Supreme Court
that put into our Constitutional fabric,
the concept of one person, one vote,
which changed, probably more
than anything, the structure of
our political government
in the United States.
- [Kim] Do you think that
our election system today
conforms to this standard
of one person, one vote?
- [Olson] Well we probably haven't
solved all of the problems,
but compared to where we were
in 1961, before Baker versus Carr,
we've really crossed that rubicon.
Most districts are relatively equal.
There is a Census every 10 years
so that we can count the
number of persons in districts.
There are still cases that come along,
there are cases involving
the allocation of persons
by race, and whether
there are systems in place
that discriminate on the basis of race.
- [Charles] Some states have passed laws
requiring voters to present
photo identification
when the voter goes to
vote at the polling place.
And one objection to the voter photo ID,
is that it's a violation of
the equal protection clause.
It's a violation of the idea of equality,
that voters are not being treated equally
vis-a-vis one another, because
some voters have voter IDs
and others have a hard time getting them
for whatever reasons.
And there might be racial
disproportional effects,
there might be class effects,
there might be gender effects.
And so this raises a violation of
the equal protection clause,
and these are the types of
arguments that are now
available to someone
challenging the problem
of inequality in voting
after Baker versus Carr that
were not available before
Baker versus Carr.
And to fully answer your question,
some people might say,
look we don't fully have
one person, one vote
because we have a lot of
laws that treat voters unequally.
- [Olson] If the
political party A controls
both houses of a legislator
in a particular state
and the person who's in
the Governor's Mansion,
then those lines can be drawn to favor
that political party so that
you might have situations
where a political party
maybe only has 40% of the
registered voters in a particular state,
but maybe 55% of the
elected representatives.
That's called political gerrymandering,
and those issues have
come before the court.
- [Charles] We still haven't achieved
the type of equality that was promised
by the Baker line of cases.
- [Kim] So we've learned
that in Baker versus Carr,
the Supreme Court ruled that redistricting
was a justiciable issue,
or something that the
federal courts could decide.
Because ensuring that
votes have equal weight
is important to ensuring equal
protection under the law.
The standard of one person, one vote
opened the flood gate for cases about
equality of representation
and districting,
which are still being litigated
at the Supreme Court today.
To learn more about Baker versus Carr,
visit the National Constitution Center's
Interactive Constitution,
and Khan Academy's resources
on US government and politics.